if you're a Trader and you're right all
the time you get paid a million pound if
you're a Trader and you're wrong with
the time you get fired if you're in the
media and you're right A year later
nobody remembers and if you're in the
media and you're wrong A year later
nobody remembers now
the problem with this is
it creates a situation where if
you are a really good Economist and you
keep making correct predictions
the media will not generally push you to
the front and if you are an economist
who works in the media and you're bad
you make very bad predictions nobody's
ever going to call you out
so what this means is if you are a
really good Economist and you want to
explain to people what's happening in
the media
how do you do it
how does the media determine who gets
the important jobs and and who gets
ignored
well if you don't have a system that
actively finds the good people and
actively discourages the bad people
basically you're going to end up with
the people who know the right people
getting into the best jobs